even though kids went back to school a
couple of months ago we might still need
some help staying organized lifestyle
expert ali levine shares some of her
must-haves
hi everyone i'm allie happy back to
school i know smiles have already
started school and i'm so excited to
share these amazing ways to help you
organize and also have so much fun with
back to school and some great hacks in
going through the school year this year
whether it be online hybrid or at home
how we can help you with some amazing
products so first i want to share with
you mabel's labels mabel's labels are
incredible labels that are easy to
stick on your clothes and have them stay
they are
laundry safe they are microwave safe
they are dishwasher safe they're they're
incredible i love all different colors
and styles they come in these really fun
labels here so when you apply your label
you just stick it to the surface that's
smooth clean and dry and then you press
down hard and it applies next i have
this incredible kit a really fun stuff
for all ages i've got busy box child
really wants you to have fun with
engaging whether it be with your kid or
letting them do it themselves we know
kids have lived on screens a lot more
than usual and we want to help them with
their sense rate play and really help
build their nerve connection their brain
and encourage the development of their
motor skills even further so these kits
come with everything you need this one
here is really fun it has all these
different unicorn styles to create with
like play-doh and different beads and
styles this one has alphabet and really
fun things to learn with letters and
she's also got some really great
subscription as well as single kits for
the holidays next i have the incredible
glam baby and speaking of screen time
you know there is uh no question that
our kids have spent way more on the
screens than usual and that may be the
reality again for many this year so glam
baby is the incredible glasses that are
to help with blue light created by a mom
and a doctor dr ariane fartaj who
understands that blue light not only
affects us adults but especially affects
our kids they're scratch free they're
durable they can be thrown around and
they won't break they won't scratch
which is awesome when you have kids go
to glam baby and check that out and
learn more about it as well as where you
can purchase your glasses and get free
shipping so i highly recommend these
especially for your kiddos that are on
the screen and next up we have the
fabulous just human so just human is a
24 hour hand sanitizer yes it's a 24
hour just human is 24 hour shield on
your hands it's non-toxic it's
alcohol-free it's moisturizing when i
put it on i was so surprised how
moisturizing it is it smells good it's
made in the usa with pride go to amazon
and look up just human and find it there
or you can just google just human hand
sanitizer and find it last but not least
i have the amazing once upon a farm i
love them i've been using their packs
with both of my daughters since they
were super young so many kids of so many
ages love them they are organic they are
cold-pressed they are delicious they
have fruit and veggie blends this one
here green apple and kale is kind of a
fun way to spice up your normal apple
sauce pack for kids at school and i love
that they're you know healthy and i know
they're getting you know a good snack or
maybe sometimes even a meal replacement
it's a busy day and the kids don't want
to eat i know they're still getting the
nutrients that they need so you can
check them out at once upon a farm.com i
hope you all have an incredible school
year and if you want to follow me and
check me out you can go to allie
levine.com for more info or follow
leandesign thanks so much